erinnern sie sich an alles dichtmachen
an diese corona kunstaktion unter
anderem mit jan josef liefers mit wotan
wilke möhring mit meret becker und an
all die diskussionen die das ausgelöst
hat die wurden alle in die ecke der
querdenker gerückt mit dieser
kunstaktion jetzt gibts sowas wie eine
fortsetzung dieser aktion alles auf den
tisch heißt genau das wieder eine video
aktion wieder mit teilweise prominenten
schauspielern wotan wilke möhring haben
sie gerade schon kurz durch wischen
gesehen und wieder geht es um corona
worum genau was ist das für eine aktion
was steckt drin bild meinem chef
philippe piatti im studio philipp ja wie
du schon gesagt hast ist wirkt wie eine
fortsetzung von alles dichtmachen sind
wieder zahlreiche videos geworden
allesamt zum thema corona aber es ist
ein großer unterschied das ist keine hau
drauf satire mehr sondern es sind 20
minütige videos jeweils immer ein
künstler ein schauspieler im gespräch
mit einem wissenschaftler oder experten
und da sind eben schauspieler wie volker
bruch wie wotan wilke möhring dabei und
experten wie der biologe klaus stöhr
beispielsweise aber auch wie der
rechtsanwalt joachim steinhöfel und da
wird alles besprochen was in der korona
krise zu kurz kam so sehen es zumindest
die schauspieler die diese aktion
gemacht haben da geht es um kinderrechte
dann geht es um angst mache da geht es
aber auch um meinungsfreiheit
beispielsweise und ich glaube wir
sollten wir vorher weitersprechen einmal
reinhören
ich hatte wie gesagt bei alles dicht an
den oder die sozialen medien ja auch das
gesamte mediale klima oder mit gesamte
stimmung auch außerhalb der sozialen
medien bestimmen können mittlerweile
haben wir dann in den sozialen medien
eine andere
oder bilden uns ein eine andere rechts
also ganz die rechtssicherheit lieber
draußen ampere gesetzbuch was als
hassrede was nicht sondern entsteht da
eine eigen einer eigenen
wir bestimmen was erlaubt und was nicht
und gar nicht mehr das gesetzbuch
also so sieht es philipp in etwa aus
davon gibt es mehrere clips und es wird
auch gefordert dass man mehr in
diskussion kommt mehr in die debatte
kommt und dass dabei auch mehr stimmen
gehört werden ganz genau das ist der
kernpunkt dieser aktion man will
wissenschaftler und experten zu wort
kommen lassen die in der korona krise
nicht so zu wort kamen wie sie zu wort
kommen sollten so sehen es zumindest die
schauspieler und künstler die diese
aktion veranstaltet haben sie sehen auf
der einen seite die wissenschaftler wie
christian drosten experten politiker wie
karl lauterbach den lkw chef lothar
wieler die alle sehr nahe am kanzleramt
dran waren die eine große mediale
öffentlichkeit dadurch auch bekommen
haben und natürlich auch wirklich auch
eine politische macht und dann
regierungskritische stimmen wie
beispielsweise klaus stöhr der zwar
medial muss man sagen nicht zu kurz kam
aber der bei den entscheidenden politik
herunten nie dabei war der ausgeladen
wurde ganz bewusst nicht gehört wurde
und deswegen auch wichtige themen nicht
gehört wurden daraus hat das kanzleramt
auch kein hehl gemacht man hat ganz
gezielt versucht sich mit experten zu
umgeben diese experten auch zu benutzen
um ministerpräsidenten auf linie zu
bringen und man hat den offenen diskurs
für den die kanzlerin ja als
wissenschaftlerin eigentlich selbst
stehen sollte den hat man versucht zu
verhindern und das wollten diese
künstler mit dieser aktion nun einmal
zeigen haben wenn man sich diese videos
genau anschaut doch immer allein
das ist noch mal reinschauen werden noch
mehr vorliegen lässt uns nochmal direkt
in die videos reingen
nehmen wir auch mal die sozialen medien
was dort mittlerweile passiert was dort
und der hassrede gelöscht werde ich
meinen bei facebook sind über 30
millionen deutsche das heißt fast jeder
zweite und wenn man sehr alte leute und
kleine kinder die noch nicht lesen und
schreiben raus nimmt so ungefähr jeder
zweite dort wird heinrich heine als
hassrede gelöscht ein authentisches
zitat oder johann josef kersting kennt
nicht jeder aber die konrad adenauer
stiftung hat den auf ihrer seite als
weltanschaulichen vorgänger der cdu hass
rede wenn man dort schreibt der dumme
deutsche michel kamera das hassrede mal
wird gelöscht und 30 tage gesperrt das
ist wie sich durch das netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz dieses klima
hassrede in den ganz normalen
gesellschaftlichen diskurs hineinfrisst
genau das war der relativ bekannte
anwalt joachim steinhöfel im gespräch
über meinungsfreiheit mit wotan wilke
möhring der meinungsfreiheit ist auch
eines ein zentrales thema auch wenn es
erst mal auf den ersten blick gar nichts
mit corona und dem virus selbst zu tun
hat natürlich aber die debatte ist halt
deutlich angespannt hat deutlich
gespalten geworden auf der einen seite
auf sozialen netzwerken wie man es jetzt
sieht und das problem bei den sozialen
netzwerken ist dass sie eben selbst
entscheiden was gesagt werden darf und
was nicht sie haben ganz eigene
richtlinien was hassrede bedeutet was
gelöscht wird das orientiert sich zum
teil auch nicht an dem was deutsche
rechtslage ist eine sehr subjektive
kriterien und meinungsfreiheit spielt ja
auch eine rolle ja auch im
wissenschaftlichen diskurs wir haben oft
dieses wort falls balance gehört
beispielsweise letztens von jan
böhmermann aber auch zum beispiel vom
spiegel wurde das oft erwähnt also falls
balance heißt das angeblich
angebliche minderheitsmeinung zu
prominent zu wort kamen konkret wurde
kritisiert dass beispielsweise hendrix
trägt der virologe dass er seine
position verbreiten durfte obwohl die
gar nicht begründet gar nicht
wissenschaftlich nicht
wissenschaftlicher konsens sein und
dieses dieses dieser versuch
wissenschaftliche stimmen aber auch
andere stimmen stumm zu schalten zu
diskreditieren zu diffamieren das kann
alles in der korona krise hoch und dem
versuchen sich diese künstler entgegen
zu stellen und wie auch mit alles
dichtmachen erneut eine debatte zu
entfachen wird dass den künstlern den
wissenschaftlern gelingen du hast ein
gutes gespür für das entstehen von
debatten wie groß wird die diskussion
rund um hashtag alles auf den tisch sie
wird nicht so groß wie alles dichtmachen
das kann ich auf jeden fall sagen alles
dichtmachen das warte so ein knalleffekt
das waren diese kurzen satirischen
bitterbösen videos mit sehr viel
prominenten gesichtern jetzt da sind
zwar volker bruch dabei wotan wilke
möhring aber das sind auch ganz viele
schauspieler dabei die vielleicht nicht
jeder kennt oder die man nicht auf den
ersten blick erkennt und es sind eben
diese 20-minütigen zum teil auch
interessanten aber eben nicht so nicht
zu knalligen interviews mit
wissenschaftlern die ich glaube da haben
auch viele nicht mitgemacht weil sie
befürchtet haben dass es erneut zu einer
reaktion kommt wie es damals war da gab
es ja kündigungs drohung der gab es
morddrohungen gab es möglich eine
unglaubliche kampagne gegen alles dicht
machen glaubt da man sich also jetzt
viele nicht getraut damit zu machen aber
man wollte auch wirklich nicht nicht
nicht das gleiche machen sondern man
wollte diesmal zeigen wir können auch
anders wir können noch ernsthafter und
wir wollen uns gar nicht selbst in den
vordergrund drängen sondern wir nutzen
unsere bekanntheit unserer prominenz als
bühne für menschen die vielleicht nicht
genug zu wort kam diesmal also ohne er
dem stilmittel der satire muss man sagen
so wie es beim letzten mal gemacht wurde
sondern in form von informativen
interviews also eine ganz andere form
gewählt diesmal um über das thema corona
und all die einschränkungen und all die
informationen die damit verbunden sind
aufmerksam zu machen wo findet man die
videos noch ganz kurz für alle die sich
auch viel zeit nehmen wollen und sich
die ganze in ruhe anschauen ich habe die
website in jetzt nicht genau im kopf ich
glaube sie lautet alles auf den tisch
punkt tv wenn ich mich nicht ganz irre
auf youtube gibt es jetzt auch ein kanal
also am besten das einfach mal bei
youtube eingeben wenn sie bei uns bei
bild.de natürlich auch verliehen rechts
erscheint er den moment bild meinem chef
für dp edh
[Musik]